People are selecting
specific fire arms,
specific ammunition,
going out into the forest
looking just to kill
this gorgeous animal.
It's not just a simple
cops and robbers model.
It's not as easy as you
know, good guys, bad guys.
We need to be able to put law
and order into the equation.
This is where I started
in Conkouati-Douli
in a park in Southern
Republic of Congo.
This elephant is one
guy that we would see
relatively frequently
and as you can see
he's got enormous tusks.
In over three years nobody
has seen this elephant.
It's a national park.
It's got boundaries.
But criminals don't care at all
about where you drew
those lines on a map.
Criminals have much
more complex networks
and their logistics go
as far as they need to.
We're not talking
about a guy hunting
to feed his family.
Wildlife trafficking is
not subsistence hunting.
We're talking about addressing
the industrial scale
problem that we're dealing with.
Leopard skin's a very tough one,
because we're trying to
catch the traffickers
but at the same time,
we know that the hunting
in the forest is
often opportunistic,
so hitting the
traffickers and getting
that message back
to the poachers
so that the trigger isn't
pulled in the first place
or the snare isn't laid in
the first place is very hard.
That is not the case of
course, when it comes to ivory
where people are selecting
specific firearms,
specific ammunition,
going out into the forest
looking just to kill
this gorgeous animal.
We're seeing some giant
seizures over in Asia.
From central Africa it's
coming from Congo, Gabon,
right smack in the
middle where we have
the best elephant populations.
You get hundreds
of kilos of ivory
going out all the
time, accumulating into
thousands of kilos
inside of big port cities
like in Lome in Togo.
Please notice that the
ammunition was an AK47 clip.
I don't know if you want to call
that a leftover from conflict
or just an excuse
for a big problem
that we need to talk
about which is corruption.
You have people in
militaries or police forces
providing ammunition to
poachers using their authority
as a cover so that they can go
and make a lot of
money off this stuff.
So who are these guys?
Everybody has this basic notion,
we have the poachers, they
give it to a trafficker,
the trafficker gives
it to a middle man,
he goes to bigger traffickers,
down the line to your kingpin.
And so from a law
enforcement perspective,
you'd think alright it's
easy, we're gonna intercept
these guys with anti-poaching
on the poachers,
some police forces
along the way,
and we'll work it out.
Gets a little bit
more complicated
when maybe someone
in your police force
is part of your network.
And I could add a
lot of other bubbles
and make this far
more complicated
when you look at who's
providing the ammunition,
who's getting them out of jail,
who is making it so
that even if they
get that strong prison sentence,
that they can still slip away
or get a fake medical
slip or something.
We have seen every
permutation of corruption
that you can imagine.
This is an operation
which we did
with the National Central
Bureau of Interpol
in Conakry where over
$30,000 was seized
and over 800 pieces of ivory.
This fellow is an
[bleep] that I really
want to put in jail.
I have put him in
jail a couple of times
and he's still doing that.
He's smiling there but
he's not smiling here
when we're trying to arrest him.
This is a failure of ours.
We failed with this guy.
He is too powerful.
We have been trying everything
to get him arrested.
His name is Ikama.
Our dogs have come in
and scanned the place,
found hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of pieces of ivory.
But this fellow got out
of jail because his son
is an ex-rebel leader, an
ex-member of parliament
and he's using every
bit of political
weight that he can get
to traffic his influence
across the Congo to make
sure that his father
doesn't go to jail,
even though is father
is one of the biggest
ivory dealers in Congo.
At the same time
he has the audacity
to go to the police
station a few weeks later
and figure out how to
get his ivory back.
So these are the
types of problems
that we have to
figure out, is babysit
these cases every
single step of the way
to make sure that he
doesn't get his ivory back.
Here's a success.
126 kilos of ivory
seized in Brazzaville.
A big trafficker,
he's got a connection
to Cameroon and into Nigeria,
he was probably going
to go on to go to Togo
and all of that stuff.
We get the dogs in,
they search the place,
the guy gets two years in jail.
The dogs do lovely
stuff on their own.
We took them into
forestry concessions,
you can't hide anything
from these dogs.
And that enables us to
prove that these camps
were not actually working
for logging concessions
or just doing their job,
and lit them on fire.
Obviously I like
playing with the dogs.
It's amazing to have live
animals around in our work.
That's the US ambassador
as well who's shaking hands
with Shon, and that's
really important for us.
We need political
leverage, we need that kind
of political weight, and
that's kind of the take home
message here is that with
all of this complicated
reality of how illegal
wildlife trafficking networks
function, we have to
accept that it's not just
this simple, cops
and robbers model.
It's not as easy as you
know, good guys, bad guys.
It's really complex, we need
a lot of political pressure
to make sure that
we're actually able
to put these guys behind bars
and neutralize them for
as long as possible.
We need to be able to put law
and order into the equation.
So spread the word
about that please
and let's not make
it a simple thing.
Let's address this problem
with the reality that it is.
Thank you very much.